[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
they're gonna riot down at the golden
corral
[Music]
if you don't make their orange deity the
king to save lindsey graham and
all the other traitors from prosecutions
oh lindsay
lady g you little [ __ ] listen this is
ridiculous this riot thing number one
they already did that they have already
tried the riot thing
and it didn't work
it did not work they got their their
most loyal supporters to come to
washington the gravy seals
to come to washington to try to
overthrow our government one of them got
[ __ ] shot over it ashley babbitt
she's even trending this morning because
of it i guess again because she's a
[ __ ] traitor
they tried this [ __ ] they tried this
riot stuff they've done did that lindsay
they they tried it look this is the
biggest [ __ ] farce this is the
biggest [ __ ] fraud that has ever been
brought on our country is what they're
talking about here they're trying to
stoke up violence from their most avid
ridiculous delusional q anon
to commit violence
to save them from prosecution and it's
not going to work it's not going to work
they couldn't save you from losing badly
in an election they're definitely not
going to save you from a prosecution
this is really [ __ ] dumb
really dumb i mean so dumb and almost
smells like crime from lindsey graham
and others
threatening the american people with
riots from
a bunch of [ __ ] toothless trump
supporters give me a [ __ ] break
give me a [ __ ] break
you done done called on your most avid
supporters to save you
in in 2020 in december they came on
january 6 they [ __ ] literally they [ __ ]
on our [ __ ] capital and our
constitution
to try to overthrow the government to
make donald trump the king
and it didn't work
they think they're going to just be able
to snap their fingers and call for
another violent insurrection where
where mar-a-lago
because a bunch of dummies are down
there in trump underwear with trump
flags
waving waving their let's go brandon
nazi flags all over the place you really
think that's gonna save you
you really think that the american
people are gonna put up with this [ __ ]
jesus christ the american people want
this [ __ ] fat slob to slink away they
wanted him to slink away after they
[ __ ] voted 8 million times against
him
more times i should say 81 million times
to [ __ ] tell him to go get [ __ ]
[ __ ] off
we don't want you anywhere near our
government and
boy we we see why now
he was a [ __ ] threat to our security
him and cash patel
run through boxes and but that's right
cash patel
i'm saying his name i'm not redacting it
[ __ ] him
him and cash patel stole
stole top secret documents from our
government
and then trying to hide them
and now
this morning the the doj is like oh that
special master you want yeah
that's not even a thing anymore we're
done done the review we done separate
the [ __ ] out that has that has attorney
client privilege
and they didn't even mention executive
privilege in this violin didn't [ __ ]
mention it because he doesn't have it
he doesn't have executive privilege it
doesn't exist because he's not the
president you d no no matter how much
fox news and oan and newsmax and all
these [ __ ] sycophants call him the
president still doesn't make him that
he's the former guy he'll be lucky he'll
be lucky to have an asterisk next to it
next to his [ __ ] name here
after the treason that he has committed
i believe that there's suspicion that
the reason why they moved on him like a
[ __ ]
and grabbed him by the top secret
documents here is because that
[ __ ]
put assets of our national security at
risk and they knew it and it came back
to him and that's why they had to move
on these documents i don't think they're
actually going to indict him until after
the election i don't think they ever
really wanted to indict him on these
charges
they didn't want to go this far with
these top secret documents they would
much rather have done this in in private
the doj take these the national archives
get their [ __ ] back
and this dumb [ __ ] move on with his with
his more of his [ __ ] chaos
and not bring the national security of
our nation into it but he couldn't help
himself
he had to you know
steal top secret documents and probably
sell them to saudis or trade them for a
[ __ ] golf tournament i don't know
we're gonna find out eventually
but it's clear now that the fbi and the
department of justice knew what
documents were there they knew what was
stolen they still probably have
suspicion of what else he [ __ ] gave
away sold or traded
and maybe not maybe they know exactly
what he did
but it's very obvious that donald trump
is a frightened little caged animal
and he's grasping at straws with this
special master [ __ ]
and the reason why is because this
morning the department of justice in
their filing gives them a schooling on
what a special master is
and that that dumb [ __ ] is too
late you're too late you were you were
out there truthing
you were out there posting dumb [ __ ]
giving away the game
talking about planted evidence and then
and then it was all they went through
melania's underwear drawer and didn't
fold their panties back right or some
[ __ ]
we locked the door we locked the door
well come to find out they said lock the
door because we're coming back to get
our [ __ ]
they knew what was there
they knew
they know
hey cash patel hey cash patel how does
how is it gonna feel to be the fall guy
for espionage
for stealing top secret documents it's
just dumb [ __ ] man it is it is
not a surprise that cash patel is one of
devin nunez's [ __ ] stooges is it not
to me i don't think so
but lindsey graham
over the weekend and others josh hawley
of course
mr fister
oh [ __ ] these guys this you just cannot
make this [ __ ] up you just cannot make
this [ __ ] up and and to make it worse to
make it worse the american people aren't
buying this garbage
they're not they're not buying this
garbage that somehow he was protecting
the american national security by
holding these documents and stuffing
them in melania's underwear drawer get
the [ __ ] out of here no one believes
that garbage besides a bunch of
delusional sycophants
and it's dwindling have you noticed that
like the trumpers get crazier and
crazier like they just get it's just
getting weirder and weirder and weirder
i watch the video patreon takes post it
maybe we'll watch it today some guy's
saying that in october that donald
trump's gonna i don't know supreme
court's gonna hold a a courtroom hearing
or some [ __ ] or
over they've suspended they'll i don't
know what the [ __ ] they're talking about
just absolute [ __ ] garbage
and it's such a huge dumpster fire this
guy i'm telling you dude is over on on
two central on fraud social over there
just freaking the [ __ ] out all weekend
even quote tweeting himself
quote tweeting himself because no one
else will do it probably over there
because their servers are about to go
down they can't get a [ __ ] trademark
to save their lives over at true social
this goddamn thing's a joke
oh who'da guessed it a donald trump
venture is going to go bankrupt go belly
up all the
world
who could have thunk it get the [ __ ] out
of here man
this is just just more par for the
course and really honestly if it didn't
affect our [ __ ] country so goddamn
much it would be even more laughable
but this is literally affecting our
country and the only people that can
save it is us
by engaging in the ballot
charlie crist is up on is is up in some
of these these unreliable polls
on ron desantis don't believe the
[ __ ] polls people these things are
garbage these things are not real it's
not worth even looking at them at this
point
just go [ __ ] engage in your democracy
lean into it [ __ ] it
don't don't don't lean back lean into it
talk to your family your friends your
your [ __ ]
parents at your kid's school in the pta
your church members your colleagues at
work just talk to them
tell show them what the [ __ ] going on
that these ninja poops these ninja poop
nazis are defending
this the former buffoon
as he's trying to justify stealing top
secret documents
and united states senators saying oh
well they're right if they charge him
with the crimes that he committed what
get the [ __ ] out of here
that's not the most egregious thing i
think lindsey graham actually said in
that interview to be quite honest i
think it's all [ __ ]
they're just cat calling they're just
cat calling all these [ __ ] these fat
toothless trump humpers on social media
to post videos
to uh
to be investigated by the fbi because
they're making threats against the
government like the guy in cincinnati or
detroit or wherever the hell it was
and then the people in arizona trying to
[ __ ]
intimidate the fbi with a bunch of
rifles get the [ __ ] out of here
this civil war talk really is stupid
it's really stupid
it's really dumb it's [ __ ] dumb
because really honestly the threat of
our democracy is not in a war in the
streets
it's not these [ __ ] people can barely
get off the [ __ ] couch and get a bag
of cheetos and their diet coke to finish
watching new jerking off to newsmax for
crying out loud
let alone let alone get out in the
streets and commit a civil war against
the government of the united states the
military get the [ __ ] out of here
the threat to our democracy is inside
our governments that's the [ __ ]
threat
the ron desantis the greg abbott's the
lindsey grahams the people who are
elected officials who are infiltrated
into our government who are [ __ ]
treasonous pieces of [ __ ] so much so
that they're willing to take away
[ __ ] rights away from american people
and the american people had enough of
this [ __ ] even in kansas they told them
no and i believe in new york's 19th they
told them to go [ __ ] themselves
in the special election where they where
they elected pat ryan
and said no we're not going to put up
with your [ __ ] republican fascist
[ __ ] anymore were you people thin veil
your your fascism with conservatism you
want to take away rights from people
it's not going to stop at women's bodily
autonomy and people know that
people know that these [ __ ] white
christian nationalists these goddamn
america first nazis are not gonna stop
at women's bodily autonomy they won't
they'll come for their vote they'll come
for your vote they'll come for your
[ __ ] freedom
and that is one thing you do not do to
the american people is come for their
[ __ ] freedom and [ __ ] on it you do
not do that
we strive for liberty here in this
country and the rights
and our freedoms grant us that liberty
and when you start threatening that we
will push back on you and we will
[ __ ] we will
we will drown you politically it's
enough of this [ __ ]
i don't i wish lindsey graham was up for
re-election again he's not he probably
cheated in his election there's no doubt
now that he's he tried to cheat
help donald trump cheat in the georgia
election and the only proof you need is
that he's not willing to go talk to the
prosecutors about it so much so that he
thinks
united states senators are served a
special privilege not to be questioned
by county prosecutors it's literally
what he said he literally said the most
dangerous [ __ ] thing that that
piece of [ __ ] said is not about the
riots as far as i'm concerned the thing
that lindsey graham is is a dangerous
[ __ ] is when he says that united
states republican senators are not to be
held account by prosecutors
that's what he said ron johnson's on the
same goddamn page ron johnson gets
called out by the january 6th select
committee for trying trying to give
the fake ass electors the fraudulent
electors the criminal illegal electors
trying to make sure that those son of a
[ __ ] got slipped in the box
so that way mike pence could just oh he
could just crown donald trump king ron
johnson you are a criminal piece of [ __ ]
people in wisconsin need to get their
asses out and lean into democracy
and absolutely dunk on ron johnson
putin's puppet send him packing back to
russia [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him
and anyone who looks like him [ __ ] ron
johnson
that piece of [ __ ] him lindsey graham
and josh holly it's just a shame that
lindsey graham and josh hawley aren't
aren't up on the ballot this cycle
just a shame isn't it
that's the only thing i regret about uh
the term limits that senators have is we
offset
those six-year terms in different states
maybe we should lower a senator's term
to two years [ __ ] them every two years
we get to fire your dumbass
maybe we can fire people like lindsey
graham ron johnson and josh holly in
this cycle
but it again
again
the biggest threat to our democracy is
not a bunch of fat dudes
in tiny [ __ ] bulletproof vests with
their little their little pea shooters
out in the streets against the united
states government that is not the threat
the threat is these [ __ ] treasonous
pieces of [ __ ] inside our government
controlling the power
rather it be the federal government in
the senate and the house which is very
important and very crucial to our
democracy safety but also inside these
state houses the governorship the
legislators the state senators all the
way down to city council county
commission and [ __ ] school boards
they want to undo our democracy jesus
christ in florida they're banning book
fairs bannon books
ron desantis doesn't even want you to
say the word fascist oh and they're
really upset about that oh they're
[ __ ] upset that that joe biden call
them what they are and really honestly
joe biden didn't go far enough he called
them semi-fascists you're not eating
semi-fascist you're [ __ ] nazis
[ __ ] semi-fascist jesus christ don't
offend the semi-fascists for crying out
loud
jesus christ semi-fascists like liz
cheney should be offended offended to be
dumped in the same category as these
[ __ ] ninja poop nazis these america
first nazis these white christian ashes
like marjorie taylor green lauren bobert
ted cruz and donald trump
the semi-fascists should be [ __ ]
offended and if i were them i would be
out saying hey you can't you can't call
them semi-fascists we're semi-fascists
we used to call ourselves conservatives
and now they've taken up our mantle and
taken our party away from us
don't put us
in the same category as the nigpoop
nazis we're the semi-fascists
liz cheney and adam kinzinger
that's right i haven't stopped there
the other thing that is more apparent
than ever
with these senators and these congress
congress people calling for violence in
the streets
is they know that the january 6 select
committee
is teeing up the ball for september
it's august 29th we got labor day week
and it's a holiday weekend but i would
imagine next week we're gonna hear an
announcement of what what days and how
many of these hearings we're going to
have in season two
of the insurrection act
where we see the january 6 select
committee reconvened they've been
tweeting like a [ __ ] they
released another video over the weekend
an extended video of some of the
evidence that they've already presented
to the american people about the fake
elector scheme uh it seems that
that this is probably the push for
department of justice to charge
uh not only not only the trump allies
john eastman jeffrey clark and some of
the others but politicians sitting
politicians members of congress and
members of the senate that they may be
they may have legal liability here
criminal liability when it comes to
these state electors i know there's a
lot of state officials that are in big
trouble over these fake electors they
knew what they were doing they knew what
they were doing was fraudulent and
criminal
and then they submitted the stupid
[ __ ] things like they were real to
the national archives
and then [ __ ] like scott perry
ron johnson and probably that idiot down
in texas ronnie jackson
who likes to fondle trump's balls
apparently
uh
they're the ones that were going to walk
these things and stuff them into the box
you remember on january 6th
on january 6 there was a box it's a
wooden box that held all the certified
electors that was the certification
that was what made it made joe biden
president not not [ __ ] the vice
president mike pence
reading those envelopes that are in that
box
you realize that right in our democracy
the states certify the votes at this
point
and they had already certified those
votes they were in the goddamn box the
only thing that was that was gonna be
done at the joint session
of the electoral college was for mike
pence to read those envelopes that's it
that's it he was just going to read them
and then they're like yeah you read them
yay we vote that you read them yay
good job buddy
and then that's it
that's it
but one what these [ __ ] wanted
to do i think this is my speculation
is that they were trying and
if you look back at the pictures on
january 6
of that wooden box that held our state
electors and that's the thing their
hours their [ __ ] hours it's our
government it's our vote
those state electors were in that wooden
box
there were several women that grabbed
that box
they knew our democracy was at stake if
that box was compromised
because our votes were held in that box
and they had the wherewithal and knew
enough to protect our democracy to grab
that box and take it off the floor
as those [ __ ]
miscreants insurrectionist treasonous
pieces of [ __ ] like ashley babbitt laid
siege on the capitol
to try to overthrow our government and
crown donald trump king because they got
butt hurt because oh the election didn't
go the way they wanted
[ __ ] fascist
snowflakes and they're paying the price
they're paying the price that's why
there's not going to be any riots
there's not going to be riots what are
you talking about the people that were
willing to riot are already [ __ ]
arrested they're already charged with
crimes hell some of them are sitting in
prison right now hell they want to give
the one guy that was a former cop they
want to give that [ __ ] 19 years
in a federal prison because they're like
look you knew what the [ __ ] you were
doing you knew what the [ __ ] you were
doing
when you were laying siege to the
capitol and beating law enforcement get
the [ __ ] out of here
you as a former cop should know and did
know
they want to give him 19 years because
that's the thing again the most loyal
avid delusional supporters
they're already arrested i mean they're
still outliers but there's thousands and
there's a thousand of them at least i
think almost a thousand cases is what
we're up to
think about that for a second think
about the sure just the sheer number the
sheer number
of there were only a thousand maybe 1500
2 000 at best
at best
when they really thought that it was
stolen from him
there was only that many that were gonna
laid siege to our government
and they want to start a civil war
when the biggest majority of those
people have already turned on trump
because they're like well he didn't
pardon me i was all [ __ ] or they're
sitting in prison or they're sitting in
detention somewhere being watched by the
government you really think you really
think that there's millions of more
people out there that are gonna take to
the streets and
kill them some libtards in the name of
donald trump get the [ __ ] out of here
riots my ass
it really is rich though
lindsey graham and others calling for
riots
because donald trump will be pros
rightly prosecuted for crimes that he
obviously committed because he's
admitting to them right out in the open
these [ __ ] continue to talk
about the riots in 2020 the rats you
know the peaceful protest
that had agitators
that agitated a peaceful protest into
the point where they they committed
false flags by burning buildings which
we have bugaloo boys that are sitting in
prison right now because they false they
they
acting like they were part of the
protest burning buildings in those areas
they always give away the game folks
they always do it they always give away
the game
they're just they're just professional
projectionist
and it it's not gonna stop
not anytime soon i mean it's gonna take
us decades to protect our democracy from
these fascists because they're out
underneath their rocks and it's gonna
take a while to get them to crawl back
underneath them
but let me reassure you of this when
donald trump when donald trump is
indicted
and he's arraigned on those charges and
he's arrested and convicted
and he's jailed oh there's going to be
people in the streets baby they are
gonna be in the [ __ ] streets and it
ain't gonna be right against that [ __ ]
we're gonna be cheering finally that
[ __ ] fascist is in prison finally
that [ __ ] fascist is where he belongs
finally that [ __ ] criminal
that god damn piece of [ __ ] grandpa
poopy pants the cheeto dust mobster is
where he belongs behind [ __ ] bars
that's going to be the celebration
that's going to be the celebration folks
celebration for democracy for justice it
will happen it's coming it's coming just
just just just wait i know it's taking a
little bit to get there but god damn
just three four months ago we had no
idea that this guy was compromising our
national security
by stealing hundreds of top secret
documents criminally
and then not giving them back criminally
and mishandling which is not a surprise
but we did not know that
and there's a lot of things we still
don't know because
all that redacted
material on the affidavit isn't because
it's good for trump it's because it's
horrible for trump and it's good for our
democracy that the department of justice
is moving on him like a [ __ ]
they can do that when you're the
department of justice you can do that
when your department you can move on him
like a [ __ ] and you can grab him you
can grab him by the top secret documents
don't go anywhere we'll be back with the
shitless roundup we'll round up all the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
right after this break
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your part in blanket
today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome back to the show monday morning
well for some of you monday afternoon
for others welcome to the johnny
michaels podcast
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific on youtube twitter and twitch
and simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page boy do we have hundreds of
new listeners welcome new listeners here
on the tony michaels podcast i want to
tell you how this works we do two hours
every single weekday two hours you can
go to our youtube channel please
subscribe to the youtube channel that
helps us out that way you do not miss an
episode i mean if you do it's okay you
can always go right back there and watch
any episode you miss also follow us on
twitter at tonymichaelspod
where we do the bone end of the week
poll
and you can download every single app
episode episode you can download every
single episode
on google spotify apple wherever you
download your podcast give us a great
review while you're there that helps out
the show
boy last week was a great week for
america
great week for america it just gets
better and better i i have a feeling
this week is going to be just as good if
not better
we already have news this morning that
basically the department of justice told
them told trump to take his special
master and stick it up his [ __ ] ass
they're like you don't need a special
master
see what happens is in the world of
legality dummy is is when we take your
[ __ ]
you have a chance at that point to get a
special master if you don't well what we
do
is we have a special team of people here
at the department of justice that do
just that on every case where there may
be privileged documents and privileged
material inside the stuff that we seized
see it's called a tate team
i'm sorry i just i can't with the taint
team stuff
i think that's better than the the
special master why why is it so
i don't know it just it feels like these
these terms for this
privileged documents
are you know
kind of
kind of sexual and a taint
team and then yeah i mean you know what
that is and then a special master you
know i get i
i don't know maybe maybe my mind's in
the [ __ ] gutter this monday morning
but anyways i
let's move away from the uh bdm stuff
anyways
the department of justice uh this
morning uh files um
a motion to trump's call for a special
master basically saying if you really
wanted a special master you should ask
one for two weeks ago because we would
have definitely granted a special master
they did in the case of rudy giuliani
they did in the case of michael cohen
where is immediately when that
property was seized when they seized the
property of michael cohen and rudy
giuliani they had a special master and
and it was requested by
the people who were who were served the
search warrant because they understood
that if you wanted a special master you
have to have a special master at first
to look through that now if the special
master isn't requested on someone who
may have privileged documents or
privileged material inside this seized
material
from his home then probably what the fbi
does is
exactly what they said they did the
department of justice says look we had a
taint team go over this material to find
anything that was that may be privileged
and they've set it aside
they've set it aside already so they've
already done what a special master would
do so this judge um i forgot i think is
judge cannon who it was uh
i shouldn't be a [ __ ] judge really
honestly i mean obviously trump put her
in the court there now for this very
reason to have a a a get out of jail
free card is what he thinks as judge was
and is in this appointment in west palm
in the district of west palm beach
where actually judge reinold has a
jurisdiction over the search warrant and
it would be judge reinold that would be
the one
who appoints a special master this
federal judge obviously does not
understand that um hopefully we can get
some movement on this judge to
uh to be stripped of her judgment it
seems like that should be the call of
action here from uh the judiciary and
the bench that she should not have her
judgment because she's she stepped out
of line here of what the uh
what the normal process is on the
federal bench in the first place and it
looks like she's granting privileges to
donald trump that don't exist to other
uh american citizens
by appeasing this special master [ __ ]
when honestly she should have said wrong
court wrong judge go get the right one
and that's what she should have said she
should have said you're in the wrong
court you're in front of the wrong judge
you got to go to the judge that did the
warrant
and has the affidavit to know this
information
because what trump's trying to do here i
believe is get to one of his sycophant
judges
that owe him that owe him something for
putting them on a federal bench he's
trying to get them to look at the
unredacted part of this affidavit
because i believe more than anything
that that's truly what they were upset
about when the affidavit was released
the affidavit was highly redacted to um
really to protect methods but i think
also what could be possible
which there's been reporting uh over the
weekend that this [ __ ] slug was
carrying boxes of documents to foreign
countries and not only that that some of
these assets these nationals in these in
these countries
that are that are giving us information
intel that provide us intel on our
enemies
to make sure we're safe and our national
security is safe
have been compromised and i don't i
don't know if we if we can confirm that
some of them have been killed or not
but the thing is with this information
that are in these boxes these top secret
documents with these human assets
these these documents only exist
in certain places of our federal
government they're highly secured no
matter what their classification when
they have to do with human assets
they are highly secured and when this
person this [ __ ] idiot him and cash
patel took out these documents thought
they had the power just to wave their
hand over them and say oh they're mine i
own them now and they're unclassified i
can use them against my federal
government i can use them to blackmail
anyone i can sell them because they're
mine whatever the [ __ ] they were trying
to do and i i would imagine that in this
court case now when these these [ __ ]
idiots cash patel
donald trump and the likes that were
that were part of this scheme to steal
these documents
whatever the motive is is going to be
figured out and i believe that's the
reason why the doj moves so fast we
don't see it yet because that's part of
the redacted part
we don't see why they move so fast but
there's information of why they move
fast
they knew those documents existed they
knew they needed them back now he they
waited long enough they put enough
security at risk it was not worth it
anymore to wait
and they went and got 27 more boxes of
the [ __ ]
and they're still combing through the
[ __ ] and again they've had two weeks to
comb through this stuff and they had
weeks and weeks and weeks before to comb
through the the first 15 boxes that's
what we saw in number 47
of the affidavit
paragraph number 47 item number 47 laid
out that there was almost 200 200
classified documents
marked confidential secret and top
secret inside those boxes that had all
the markings of information that should
have been held in a skiff not in a
[ __ ] pool house or the basement of
some [ __ ] buffoon at mar-a-lago
this is really [ __ ] stupid and really
honestly
politically speaking the republicans
digging in here over the weekend that
this is some kind of witch hunt and all
this [ __ ]
and somehow he's being wronged here and
oh it's just what what's the big idea
what's the big deal it's just a bunch of
paper yeah keep with that narrative dumb
[ __ ]
honestly we should politicize the
ever-loving [ __ ] out of this just like i
say we should do everything else
everything else
we should politicize every [ __ ]
measure
because honestly it's all tied together
rather you're pissed off this election
about them taking away your [ __ ]
rights or taking away your daughter's
rights or your wife's rights or your
sister's rights or your mom's rights
from health care [ __ ] health care
people
taking away their bodily autonomy for
their [ __ ] healthcare decisions
if you're pissed off about that that's
the same goddamn thing you want the
[ __ ] who are who are derelict
in their duty to call out donald trump
and say no i don't care if he's the
greatest president on earth he should
not be
not have nationals defense information
inside melania's [ __ ] underwear
drawer that's not an appropriate place
for it he's compromising our national
security you don't even have the
wherewithal in the guts to do that get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] you
want those people in charge of your
rights and your liberty you want them in
charge of your economy
you want them to try to help you with
[ __ ] getting health care getting
educated those are the people that can't
even [ __ ] pluck their head out of
their ass long enough to realize that
this guy is a threat to our national
security and has been since he came down
that golden escalator and demonized
brown people
well
then you're in trouble
because it's all the same [ __ ]
thing
and you got to politicize it you got to
message it that way and what i mean is
is when you're out there engaging in
your democracy because that's what you
gotta do you just gotta talk to folks it
really isn't that hard i mean you gotta
vote you have to [ __ ] vote you have
to vote and you may you you may be good
at registering people to vote go do that
you may be good at text messaging you
may be good at making phone calls you
may have an extra spare change in your
pocket to put to some of these campaigns
to defeat ron johnson to defeat jd vance
to defeat dr oz to defeat [ __ ]
herschel walker that crazy bastard we're
gonna watch some video on herschel
walker
today in the shitless roundup you can
damn well better bet that to beat marco
rubio and ron desantis in florida
they're on their heels baby they're on
their heels all you got to do is lean
into this son of a [ __ ] and show them
what democracy can [ __ ] do that's all
you got to do beto beto betto's got a
damn good chance in texas
and i'll tell you what there's not going
to be anything scarier to these [ __ ]
fascists than ron desantis losing to
charlie crist in florida and greg abbott
losing to beto o'rourke in texas think
about that for a second think about the
implications going forward for the next
election
if if they can get enough people
registered enough people understand why
our democracy is so important and why
it's so important to make a decision of
someone who is willing to stand with our
democracy that's the line that's the bar
and that state makes that decision and
[ __ ] 86 is ron desantis and greg
abbott they're terrified because do you
know what that means if there's enough
registered people to make that decision
to not [ __ ] elect a fascist in their
goddamn state government they probably
won't put one in power in the federal
government do you have any idea what
happens
do you know how how irrelevant the
electoral college is in the republicans
minds and their brains even trying to
cheat if they can't get texas and
florida they are [ __ ]
capital f-u-c-k [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] for any
kind of national election
not even gonna be dreamed to happen
so we got them on their heels we the
people
it's your powers in your hand now all
you've got to do is lean into and i keep
hearing people oh well they're trying to
rig the vote and they're trying to
gerrymander redistrict yeah more reason
to [ __ ] lean into it
you want more goddamn reason there's
another goddamn reason they're trying to
rig it against you
you better lean into democracy while you
still have it
more of a reason not less of a reason
this idea that oh both sides are the
same and they're both trying to get the
[ __ ] out of here with that nonsense
that is all [ __ ]
both sides are not the same there are no
two sides there are no two sides
there is people who are pro-democracy
and the fascist
and the fascist the [ __ ] nazis
they're not semi-fascist [ __ ] them
they're nazis
and they're coming for your [ __ ] they're
coming for your way of life they want to
marry your children they want to tell
you what you can and cannot do with your
body you that they want to tell you what
your doctor can tell you not to do
with your [ __ ] body and medical
decisions even if your life is at risk
so what are you going to do what are you
going to do you're going to sit at home
you're going to not talk to someone
because it's uncomfortable to talk about
how the [ __ ] republicans are banning
book fairs and banning books
they're banning math because of crt
the numbers are on your side
pro-democracy folks there's no question
there are a whole lot more people out
there who value their democracy than
than undervalue it are our think that
we're a republic we're not a democracy
what the [ __ ] you think a republic is
so do your do your do your duty to your
democracy and lean into that
[ __ ] lean into it
get with it
it's okay there's plenty of us out there
to support you
and i know even if you live in red areas
like i live
they i'm telling you
i'm telling you right now
the mood is changing the tide is turning
people do not want to support a
treasonous piece of [ __ ] i mean yeah
you're still gonna have the deluded
cuban honors but that's a big ass fraud
that somehow that's a big percentage of
our country that's all nonsense i mean
i'm gonna show you some deluded
[ __ ] today that try to round up
the few thousand people that are still
left that are still believing this
garbage
but now in between now and the time of
the election we have a chance to prove
to these people that yes
yes what people are saying is true
they're trying to steal your [ __ ]
rights they're trying to steal your
liberty
a row is just one example florida is the
blueprint for what they want they don't
want you to read [ __ ] books they
don't want you to be [ __ ] educated
it's obvious that
freaking out about student loan debt
relief ten thousand dollars get the [ __ ]
out of who who in this country
still if you're an adult in this country
and know how much [ __ ] cost
how much college costs knows that ten
thousand dollars is is just barely some
relief
it's going to help a lot of americans 45
of all student debt is going to be
relieved what what is left of it
and yeah it's gonna help americans but
to act like ten thousand dollars is
sometime somehow some [ __ ] big
giveaway get the [ __ ] out of here you
ppp forgiveness alone having
[ __ ] get out of here with that
nonsense
well i've got a lot of video to show you
gabe sanchez should be joining us just
in a bit so let's do this let's start
the countdown and get to the [ __ ] list
roundup right now let's surf the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends let's start
the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back to the show you have
reached the part of the show where we
round up all the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends called the [ __ ] list
roundup
uh we got a lot of video to get to today
and let me tell you we got a lot of new
viewers here today i want to tell you
how this works every single weekday
monday through friday for two full hours
we are live here on youtube twitter and
twitch noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific we also simulcast from the midas
touch facebook page so don't miss a
single episode if you're here subscribe
to the youtube channel you're not going
to want to miss a goddamn thing because
i do not hold back as folks know it's
real and it's raw and i do not give a
flying [ __ ] about your feelings i don't
give a [ __ ] especially these [ __ ]
fascists and honestly joe biden was not
tough enough on these son of a [ __ ]
was not tough enough here is um oh here
here's
here's here's here's rhona mcdaniel
romney uh whining and crying about being
called a semi-fascist i believe she's
really upset she's really upset that joe
biden called her a semi-fast you're a
[ __ ] nazi i don't give a [ __ ] what
joe biden calls you he didn't go far
enough
frankly the joe biden dark biden needs
to rise up
rise up and call these ninka poop nazis
what they really are these america first
fascists [ __ ] that semi-fascism [ __ ]
[ __ ] that they doubled on a division
they use fear
they call republicans names and i think
oh we call you yeah we call you names we
call you what you are we call you what
you are i don't know why you don't
understand this why are you still crying
about it you're the ones who are
participating in [ __ ] neo-fascism i
think the american people are really
sick of it right now because right now
people are hurting they are worried she
seems exhausted doesn't she doesn't she
seem exhausted to try to keep making
these stupid [ __ ] arguments that
somehow the american people are tired of
of of jill biden's [ __ ] and tired of
pro-democracy the pro-democracy party's
[ __ ] because there's only one party
in this country that is even interested
in democracy that they're not sick and
tired of your nonsense ronald mcdaniel
your [ __ ] organization the republican
national committee telling them what the
[ __ ] they can and can't do with their
bodies who the [ __ ] they can and can't
love what books they can and can't
[ __ ] read you are the one that we're
[ __ ] tired of dummy stop with the
projection but really honestly she feels
she feels exhausted in this interview
like oh god i gotta i gotta say this
argument again which is i know is not
true it's the exact opposite of this
argument
but she feels exhausted to me let's
let's listen about their livelihood
their money is is not coming in at the
level they need to to keep up with
expenses we know inflation is an issue
we know that drugs are an issue and so
they're saying why are you continuing to
double down on division can we just talk
about how we fix problems that everyday
americans are feeling right uh the
president united states is actually
trying to fix those problems it's
republicans standing in the way rona
that's the problem
that's the problem is republicans are
standing away that [ __ ] progress
because you listen to little little
[ __ ] ninka poops out there like this
[ __ ] idiot mark levin i don't know if
you guys know who mark levin is he he's
he's a reagan republican he loved reagan
i used to suck suck reagan off every
[ __ ] day on his show on his radio
show he loves him loves raking and
honestly when donald trump was running
he was so he was one of the most
anti-trump trump to anti-trump
republicans hated trump thought he was
an idiot thought he was a [ __ ]
buffoon no way this guy's going to be
successful that's what mark levin was
saying
mark levin is sold out he's a [ __ ]
sellout
he's a goddamn fascist has been for
years
so of course he sold out to trump and
and for his fascism not semi-fascism
they're nazis let's listen to this nazi
talk about how it's unfair or some [ __ ]
of the president i don't know let's
listen but before we go to our great
guests let me ask you a question oh more
with the [ __ ] questions with fox news
more with the [ __ ] questions these
[ __ ] guys him and tucker carlson with
their questions
no there's no question you are a bunch
of [ __ ] idiots that's what you are
that's the i mean that's the question
you're gonna ask here but let's listen
if you're going to commit a crime
oh
so now we're talking about who's
committing crime okay this hey we're
making progress baby now he wants to
know about crime okay we're making
progress let's hear it mark do you keep
the
video cameras in your home on 24 7.
okay
oh so
this is this is where mark levin is
doing what i've described the last few
weeks
when we found out that donald trump was
watching
the closed circuit television the
security cameras
while they were
while they were executing the search
warrant of his house at mar-a-lago when
they were taking the [ __ ] that he didn't
want them to take now it's more clear
now than ever
if you've read any part of this [ __ ]
that is unredacted on this affidavit
that
the reason why the fbi and the
department of justice didn't want those
cameras on is because they didn't want
donald trump seeing what they did and
didn't take
because he's watching to see what they
are they took so he knows what documents
he still got left to sell to the saudis
and the putin you know he's doing
inventory is what he's doing but mark
levin
walks straight into it here
walks straight into it
which i've been saying for weeks that
everyone claims he's some kind of
mobster and i call him the cheeto dust
mobster
you know because i figured that that
if he was a mobster that's that would be
his mobster name cheeto dust
the cheeto dust king but here's the
thing if he is a mobster if he really is
he's a dumbest [ __ ] mobster ever
because mark you're right why would
anyone anyone who is committing crime
that donald trump obviously was
committing
by toting around [ __ ] boxes of top
secret documents by not securing them
properly moving them from room to room
and having any old russian and any old
any old chinese national
any old russian spy put their little
dirty little grubby hands on them
i wonder
i wonder
well here's the thing mark you walk
straight into it he is an idiot he's
stupid listen
i don't know would you
seems kind of stupid doesn't it yeah it
is stupid that's why that's why you're
stupid for supporting him this is really
[ __ ] dumb
it's really dumb do we have to keep keep
doing this i'll show you another
i'll show you another
round of stupidity here might as touch
points it out with cash patel and trey
gowdy here
this is august 22nd is the first clip
and august 28th less than a week later
let's hear the difference in the talk
here let's see if you let's see if you
can spot it now they're trying to hide
behind this magistrate judge who is
going to supposedly play this game of
redactions we saw yeah yeah we want cash
patel does not want any of this redacted
right none of it none of it should be
redacted we should be able to see
exactly what the department of justice
is going to charge me with that's what
cash patel wants cash patel wants to
make sure he knows exactly what charges
he's going to be indicted on and when
he's going to be indicted on it and what
he can expect from from that indictment
that way he can gather up his legal
evidence to mount the defense give me a
break
but listen to what trey gowdy says not
less than six weeks six days not
not six weeks six days
after when they did un-redact just like
cash patel was calling for to unreact
where they unredacted his name making
him an obvious target
of the of the actual
court of public opinion that he's a
[ __ ] traitor on russiagate and when i
was at deputy dni we lifted all those
redactions from the russia gate
dachshund what did we see mark
corruption fbi and yeah corruption is
that what happened the law is that jay
left his name unredacted thereby
endangering a witness
and they wonder why people think
there's a double standard
there's a double standard people wonder
why there's a double standard trey gowdy
who [ __ ] who [ __ ]
ran the goddamn select committee to
attack hillary clinton in her campaign
where she went in and testified for 11
hours in front of that [ __ ] 11
hours she testifying under the oath
testified 11 hours under oath
and and they think it's a double
standard they can't even get this
[ __ ] guy to shut his [ __ ] mouth on
his fraud social [ __ ] out of here with
this nonsense just a bunch of [ __ ]
call it out like i see him i'm not gonna
stop okay
let's see what else do we have oh here's
here we go here's here's lindsey graham
um
lindsay lady g so let's start the lady g
clips gotta get into that let's listen
say this
if there's a prosecution of donald trump
for mishandling classified information
after the clinton debacle which you
presided over and did a hell of a good
job there'll be riots in the streets
[Laughter]
uh everyone's really upset about this
clip they're really upset they're like
oh
get the fbi to investigate their fbi is
already probably investigating lindsey
graham at this point that's why that's
why he's trying to call for for all
these toothless
[ __ ] trump supporters to take to the
streets to save him this is really dumb
[ __ ] again this is really stupid [ __ ] i
mean just listen to it again remember
remember the context here he's again
he's talking to trey gowdy
who investigated hillary clinton about
benghazi benghazi benghazi benghazi
benghazi you remember that [ __ ] on and
on and on and on it went for two [ __ ]
years
even after the email lady went and
testified for 11 hours in front of those
[ __ ] 11 hours she had the guts
to go testify
but listen and lindsey graham lindsey
graham can't even go and testify in the
state of [ __ ] georgia you piece of
[ __ ] garbage for a couple hours
so for georgia to sniff out his crime
where he was trying to overturn the
election he was using his senate seat
his power that that the people in south
carolina gave him to subvert and to
fraudulently move an election and votes
in georgia listen to how he describes
his two trey gowdy say this
if there's a prosecution of donald trump
for mishandling classified information
after the clinton debacle which you
presided over and did a hell of a good
job if trey dowdy did such a good job
and presided over it and it was a
clinton debacle and she was supposed to
be indicted and be in prison how did he
do such a good job folks
the reason why is because there was
nothing there there was nothing there
there was never anything there
hillary clinton as as
derelict as she may have been into
having emails on her private server
which when she started a secretary's
date was a normal thing by the way
and then when the policy changed she
didn't do that and she may have put risk
that someone could possibly hack that
server which they never did they never
could prove that they did
and then the benghazi thing 11 [ __ ]
hours 11 hours folks trey gowdy
questioned her
nothing turned up nothing
they even had to file a report saying
yeah we didn't find [ __ ]
so lindsay you're out of your mind and
then the best part is here again let's
listen there'll be riots in the streets
we're threatening you with with donald
trump's supporters
as they wave their treasonous flags on
their pickup trucks get the [ __ ] out of
here this is the same stupid nonsense
when they were gonna have the trucker
convoy you remember that they were gonna
shut down the government and shut down
the roads and the truckers were all
gonna strike
or some stupid dumb [ __ ]
who knows
who knows
[ __ ] gets more and more ridiculous but
this right here this clip right here
i believe this is the right clip this is
the clip that actually pisses me off way
more than the riot talk let's listen
all right before i let you go the
district attorney in georgia is
apparently a huge fan of yours um and
she's even willing to go to court for
for a chance to meet you in person
that's how much she wants to meet you in
person oh he's making such a joke oh
it's so funny
[Laughter]
it's so funny
oh i i well you wanna get the [ __ ] out
of here
why number one why is trey gowdy hosting
a show on fox news
why
who would watch this this this pencil
neck piece of [ __ ]
but listen listen to what he says next
because this is this is brilliant andre
gowdy's part because he gets lindsey
graham like hey hey yeah yeah oh wait
listen oh look
you and i are laughing it's actually
really serious i mean yeah it is really
serious oh drake out he's like look it's
really serious when a united states
sitting senator from a different state
than georgia tries to cause georgia
officials using his standing in the
republican party and his seat in south
carolina to try to elbow his way in to
make election
officials to overturn an election oh man
that is some really serious [ __ ] that's
some serious crime that you committed
there lindsay
that's what it feels like to me and then
i feel like do you look at lindsay's
face like oh i didn't know you were
gonna say that watch watch watch the
response here of lindsey graham he and
and this i think more than anything
is the thing that you as a people and as
a democracy have to put a stop to and
you can this nonsense this [ __ ]
nonsense that lindsey graham pukes up
out of his mouth listen can all members
of the house and senate begin to block
off time for state prosecutors going
forward is that where we are
well if we let county prosecutors uh
start calling senators and members of
congress as witnesses when they're doing
their job then you're going to throw out
a kill to our constitutional balance
here i've got a good legal case i'm
going to pursue it but okay gabe sanchez
apparently lindsey graham thinks that
united states knitting senators and
members of congress are way above the
law and they absolutely they absolutely
do not have to even consider that there
are even county prosecutors that can
prosecute their crimes inside states
what the what the [ __ ] is wrong with
this guy
yeah well you know that's what happens
when a party gets
a little too
filled up with their own uh ego and they
think that they are
you know i don't know the way it's
described this but they think that
they're kind of uh invincible right like
there's enough like hubris is a hell of
a drug right right right right well and
apparently it that trumpism is a hell of
a drug too right well i mean i think
they've gotten so used to getting that
high which is
trumpism and that
anything they do there's no issue
there's uh it you can always dismiss it
as fake news it's not real it's against
the you know going against mainstream
media because they're against you you're
the victim i'm the one who's the
oppressed one in this situation despite
the fact that these are people who are
elites people who are of of uh
have
um
you know
a certain amount of wealth right that is
is greatly disportionate to the overall
average population in america that they
represent right these are people that
write laws but you see them you know
bow down before trump say oh no this
wasn't an insurrection this was just a
tourist visit oh no he did nothing wrong
he's totally in the right oh those
documents he totally has the right to
have those documents he's he he took his
work home with him he was scrapbooking
he was keeping mementos well and they're
his they're his they're not ours they're
his they're his property
he he waved his hand over him and said
that so that means well yeah i mean like
he had his his tiny little hand and he
just waved it over and he's like
declassify wait is that what it is is it
the hands the size of the hands that
makes it to where he can declassify
things it might be he's like these
little hands get on this little tiny
copy of print
declassify
i wouldn't put it past them to try to
make that argument in court because
you know the the court this morning well
the doj this morning files their brief
in this court and it's like yeah you
don't need a special master we already
did that [ __ ] yeah like we we've been
doing our job i don't know what i don't
know what grandpa's been doing yelling
and screaming on fraud social well we've
been doing our job over here he you know
he claims that
uh
he declassified these documents right
cash mattel is like oh yeah i was with
him in december and january i helped him
come in i was there i was a witness to
this right it was like you might you
probably want to get a lawyer now right
uh but it is that simple where he's like
oh well
the process in which i declassify them
was via social media via truth social
the company that i'm currently stiffing
my vendors on
well not only that i can't even get a
trademark yeah they can't even get a
trademark you know this is one of those
things where it's like you know it's
supposed to be the king of trademarks
and he's supposed to be like the
candidate
he says he's got the business acumen art
of the deal he is the best
the best businessman you know like
seems like a dumb [ __ ] to me i mean i'm
just saying oh yeah 100 i mean it is it
is
if you surround yourself by enough
people right if you have certain amount
of wealth or or uh influence or power
like and you're around enough people
that
kind of feed that ego
you will 100 think that you can do
whatever you want and if you have years
of that without any sort of repercussion
or any sort of backlash right you maybe
pay a fine here or go to settle this
lawsuit there but in the in the overall
you're like i'm up i'm batting a
thousand right which is like that
doesn't make any sense and so in this
moment right now you've got trump who
thinks that those documents are his and
if he takes him to mar-a-lago they're
his property and then you got
republicans who are feeding that ego by
saying oh yeah he's totally within the
right to have those documents those are
his he's keeping them yeah look he's
like a guy who takes his homework with
him or like he's taking his work home
with him right he's that dedicated it's
like if he's the former president and
has no right to make calls as the
president the current president which is
joe biden then why would he need to take
them home
why would he need to travel with them
right yeah
we heard this over we heard this over
the right stephanie grisham coming you
know revealing that he was traveling
internationally
outside of the country which is like why
would everybody travel outside of the
state with these boxes when was he
traveling outside the country with these
boxes well it sounded like his president
it sounded like he was while he was
president because stephanie grisham
already left the administration by that
right right and i had seen a bunch of
people online who's like oh i haven't
seen anything about this like so any
person from the trump administration who
goes against your narrative you
immediately dismiss them as fake news
right
that that's that's well they did that
all they did that with john bolton when
john bolton's like of course this [ __ ]
[ __ ] is dis
mishandling doc uh classified documents
he did it his entire presidency he never
followed security protocol right he was
always a buffoon he said and not only
that the guy is not interested in this
stuff he doesn't know what's in these
boxes and my guess is is that's what
cash patel is involvement is this is
cash mattel's involvement was to find
him the ones that were he was he was
going to be able to to hold blackmail
over the united states government to
crown him king and he was going to be
able to sell the saudis and russians go
find me the stuff that is going to be
most valuable to blackmail into cell and
then out
and grab that stuff morning we'll take
it down to mar-a-lago we'll put it in
melania's underwear drawer where to be
safe because not possessions is
nine-tenths of the law i i almost bet
can you imagine can you imagine sitting
at betminster right now he's sitting
there eating his happy meal right he's
eating he's eating his fifth happy meal
and he's having conversation
cheeseburgers flying out of his mouth
and he's like possession's nine tenths
of the law that's what that's what i
know that you know he's like i i heard i
saw that online you know like anything
that he hears that is you know because
trump his world
only only can survive on confirmation
bias right he hears something he says
that's true and i need someone else to
confirm this and those people are just
trying to make him happy so it's just
like cycle of of them just confirming
his own well you see it on true social
this weekend you see it on true social
like every single post is like well
that's a lie and that's a lie and that's
a lie and that's lie like all of it the
entire run-on sentence is an entire
[ __ ] line yeah well i mean it's also
an admission that he's projecting his
own
his own kind of fear
and saying like oh
they
they have they have done something
historically that has never been done to
a former president ever they've attacked
him they have raided his home and it's
like look cuz he's a criminal yeah look
no one if you had given up the documents
that had that they had been asking for
about a year and a half or so right uh
then this wouldn't be an issue one it's
like you didn't need to take them and
even if you did take them in the
original time the the first time they're
like hey looks like we have some missing
documents do you have them we're pretty
sure you do so can you give it to us if
they're like oh [ __ ] sorry it got packed
in for whatever reason which is the bs
answer but even if they were like oh
yeah oops it got packed into the u-haul
we brought it down they gave him that
chance right they gave him that chance
they were like look we'll give you the
benefit of the doubt and say that you
[ __ ] up because we know you [ __ ] up
all during your presidency so we should
say you just [ __ ] up on this move
can you give us the documents and he
goes he could have if he really was
helpful to be like yeah cool here are
the boxes documents i don't know why we
had all these documents
don't ask me but i was you know
obviously involved with someone who is
getting those documents
then then you have a year and a half or
a year or so where they're asking for
these documents they're going back
collecting me like nope still missing
these documents do you have these
documents great in june
they're like hey we know you have these
documents and it sounds like the reason
they're like put a another [ __ ] lock
on that door is not to touch the
evidence right and then he goes in there
and it says that it says that in the
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] unredacted part
it says
you you i'm telling you the fbi agent is
telling trump and his team i'm telling
you put a lock on that door in other
words and what what it is is probably a
seal right
so that they that the the fbi knows that
you did not go into that room and you
did not touch anything in that room yes
because it's a crime scene right it is a
cri it is the same thing you would see
because it also says don't take anything
out of that room right yeah that that
not a piece of paper not a [ __ ] piece
of garbage not a dust bunny do not take
anything out of that room put that [ __ ]
in there and seal it up leave it in
there we are coming back for it yeah and
you know i think
there is also reports over the weekend
that there's possible um federal assets
uh nationals in other countries who have
been
giving us intel for years and years and
years um trying to keep us safe around
the world um i mean there's also
right exactly there's that whole talk of
during 2021 we had the most amount of
over like international assets you know
undercover you know and disclosed uh
identities that had been killed
and that was well and that's and that
and and the fbi and the department of
justice and the intel community would
have more insight if they knew exactly
the source of it and if donald trump had
the documents that reveal these people
they know the source now because those
human asset documents are not supposed
to doesn't matter what the
classification it doesn't even matter if
they're declassified this nonsense about
classified declassified is nonsense
because these human these human um asset
that that expose the human assets that
we have around the world they're
supposed to only be viewed in certain
secure areas which mar-a-lago and
melania's closet is not one of those
areas nope and and i i i think that the
reason why they had to move so fast is
because there must have been evidence
inside those first 15 boxes and there
must have been some evidence somewhere
that suggested hey
this guy is going to compromise our
national security it's a real risk we
got to go get this [ __ ] we can't we
can't wait any longer we can't wait
around and play footsie with this
fascist any longer we just got to do our
duty and go get the son of a [ __ ] and
i also believe that when they talk about
informants there were many informants
and i think texas paul
he said it a few weeks ago i think he's
right that
secret service was doing their duty here
against enemies foreign and domestic
being the right word there and they were
like hey this you gotta come get this
guy's out of control this lunatic is
gonna get someone killed um and and i
think
all that compounding on top is what is
redacted inside that affidavit right
i mean even over this weekend you know
you brought up trey gowdy uh you know
talking to
shocking lindsey graham but even he
you know within
six days i think it was six days
you know cash patel was like oh we gotta
you know
yeah right unredacted show everything
blah blah blah i can't believe that
name yeah and now they're like murmur
you know the off brand walmart wish.com
version of [ __ ] anderson cooper trey
gowdy decides that he
says oh it's not fair
wait wait wait you think trey gowdy is
fox news's um have you ever seen him
with glasses on
no i haven't yeah yeah is that is that
their rebuttal to anderson cooper
they're like oh cnn's got anderson
cooper
we'll raise you anderson goober and
we'll give you the fascist trey gowdy
yeah i mean
that's pretty much here it's kind of a
horror show though like tree gowdy is a
[ __ ] horror show yeah i mean you know
he's like what nightmares are made out
of like yeah he's he's up there with
stephen miller and and and and jared
kushner and and and some of these others
are being like you tell me and show this
to the audience you tell me that that
trey gowdy is not trying to appear
like anderson cooper
so you think he's trying to copy him is
what you're saying i don't know it looks
like a copy but like something got
messed up oh
hmm
that is kind of weird i don't know i'm
just saying hey look look i'm just
asking questions okay that's right i'm
just asking questions
well these are these are reasonable
questions to ask especially on a
platform like this i think you're right
i think i think um fox news has hired
troy gality as their fascist answer to
they needed
you know they like their own little
anderson they're like we need to we need
a little doppelganger here to confuse
the libs right right uh man yeah well
speaking of which i saw i don't know if
you saw this i saw a photo this weekend
and i i meant to tweet i'll probably
tweet it on a second okay
it's uh here you know what i'll tweet it
out right now what did you look at him
it's a photo of a dude holding up a
shirt that says how he lubricates his
ar-15 yes i've seen that before that's
been out there for a while right and i
thought at first it was a god damn
i thought it was a joke right i thought
you thought it was i thought it was
photoshopped the first time i saw it no
i was like surely it it means tears not
the other word
well no that would make sense right like
that one made sense i just uh i just
tweeted it
here's the thing there is a version that
says it's libera it's lubricated with
liberal tears okay so i went
i went online after i saw this version
of this shirt and i was like this has to
be a [ __ ] joke right this has to be a
joke
and then i went on and i looked up all
of the stores online which by the way
they all copy each other
but i went online to look up this shirt
and they are no joke they're sold
by
yeah
it's not it's not like a joke it is not
done ironically not done comically it's
not done it's some weird ass [ __ ] okay
well here here let me let me tell the
audience who are listening on the
podcast directories because you can
download the show every single weekday
on the podcast directors apple spotify
google so if you're listening over there
on podcast richard you can't see this
picture and you might want to come
subscribe to the youtube channel just
for instances like this where you can
fast forward to your time stamp to see
the picture that we're talking about but
here seems a guy um
who may or may not be closeted i'm not
really sure what closet this is inside
of but
he's holding up a shirt that has a a red
gun on it it appears to be an ar-15 i
think that's what they're claiming here
um it's kind of hard to tell because
it's you know it's great artwork okay
but but the words on it say i lubricate
my ar-15
with liberal [ __ ]
now
this is they spell it [ __ ] too like come
like you know
someone would masturbate and
come right yeah no yeah number one why
do they always make everything so sick
what is with these people
you know i think we've we've talked
about on the show it's this projection
this insecurity that they have where
they need to look up someone's skirt or
pull down someone's pants or go into
someone's house or walk into a bathroom
and and know what their gender is you
know right they're obsessed with gender
right
but this this image right here and like
i said i went online and i i you know
i looked for this search and found it in
multiple places across
different different like shirt making
websites
all of them
not done as a joke
uh
it's
i wonder i wonder if he got this as a
gift and he's happy that he got this as
a gift or if he like bought this and it
finally came in and he opened the
package and he was so excited he wanted
his right his i mean i have i think his
beard to take a picture i guess there's
there's two there's two things i can
assume here one is he knew what he
received or what he purchased
and he's okay with it which is totally
fine
it is a little bit weird that you're
collecting liberal [ __ ] it is lubricated
like one i mean i don't even want it
there's a lot of questions like how they
got it what they did you know why they
had at some point at some point [ __ ]
isn't a very good lubricant in the first
place i mean really if you think about
it right right and neither would tears
tears are salty and salt that type of
that type of residue
okay it doesn't make any sense but let's
talk about the tear thing for a second
right isn't that the word that's
supposed to be here i mean that's yes so
there is a version and you're reading it
when you're reading it when you're
reading it before you get to come you're
thinking it's going to say tears and
you're like right whoa wait a second
that's a wild right turn yeah two from
tears to you want to watch me jerk off
that's really weird you want to watch me
cry i want to like i don't you know
again no judgment i just don't know why
that's the immediate thing that you
would think of like it's like hey i i
take care of my ar-15 great cool i'm a
i'm a responsible gun owner of an ar-15
cool whatever i lubricate my ar-15 with
anything uh that isn't just a normal
like oil or like you know
a lubricant an actual lubricant it's
like you know what's better tears
come it's like uh
why do you have those things right why
why did you get them why do you think
that that is how does one procure a
liberal come is there like a
certification is there like a group out
there that certifies that it's liberal
i'm just wondering here i think i've
never been approached i mean i consider
myself a liberal right and i've never
been approached to um donate or sell
my uh lubricant i don't know i don't
know i don't know who knows maybe
there's like some clinics out there like
yeah give your donation you know like a
website if you can and then sell your
life which is also weird which is also
weird if you think about it because it's
like oh masturbation in you know in
catholicism they think it's a sin
to masturbate right because you're
you're killing the seed right and other
crazy religious wright would also think
that so i'm like why so so you're
lubricating your gun with
with what would be a dead baby
it's very it's
there's so many questions here that this
guy
and i guess the question i have is
because i know the internet has done its
thing here have we found out who who
this who this gentleman is who is so
proud owner of oh i'm sure i'm sure
somewhere
i'm sure somewhere somebody found out
they're like because you know and again
again i am just
using deductive reasoning here because
on this guy's shirt that he's wearing
he's he may be wearing another liberal
[ __ ] t-shirt you just can't see what this
logo is
now he's got a hat on that appears to be
you know it it definitely appears to be
trumpian type [ __ ] you know yeah with
the flag and i'm not it's a blue it's a
blue stripe right there it's a blue
lives matter blue lives matter so it's
obvious that that this is not done out
of irony this is not satire this is not
a joke
but that's what i want to know about
this guy i want to know who this guy is
and i'm not like his name but like right
right you know what has been his prior
activity um with liberals
yeah
i mean i i
just it's one of those shirts it's like
oh man i don't want it
but i want it for my maggot character
that i'll do like i just feel like that
shirt in of itself on top of the i'm a
huge hypocrite or i do my own research
kind of don't you like don't you think
that that kind of um i mean it would
replace it with obviously liberal it
would go to republican income but right
right well this is more of this
this nonsense um where they make
everything sexual everything is sexual
yeah over the weekend uh bobo
um
lauren bobert yeah bobo the clown
she tweeted something about
lesbian dance theory oh this is really
[ __ ] dumb
um lesbian dance theory but someone
posted this picture
speaking of pictures and question
questioning things this is a picture of
don junior booger sugar junior and
kimberly guilfoyle um posing with
someone and they said is this the
lesbian dance theory
the problem is this is from the 2020
election i feel like i've pointed out
this photo
you know and i'm not sure
you know i don't know i don't want to
misgender anyone i really don't um but
kimberly seems really off put that
the the boot in the face type thing and
you think it was planned they're like
let's take a photo and the person's like
you know i i just
put their leg up and then it was like
all right i don't know if they like
during the picture they just all of a
sudden kicked it up don didn't notice
and kimberly standing like oh [ __ ]
yeah his legs in the air sure i i don't
know i don't want to misgender this
person um but obviously there is um
an obvious thing here so people were
pointing that out that i'm not sure
what um what's going on here but um it's
very
weird
to uh pose in a picture like this i
don't know this person's famous for
holding their leg like that i don't know
it's very odd i've seen
i've seen a version of this i think this
is the original i've seen a photoshop
version with someone okay i'm blanking
on who it is
it was someone else from the republican
party but uh it is
it's i don't know like
it's it is one of those things
i mean you just can't make this [ __ ] up
right like right you can't make this
[ __ ] up um
you just can't just like you can't make
up some of the [ __ ] that these uh these
candidates are saying like herschel
walker if you can even understand what
the hell they're saying um here is
here's him this is hilarious he's
standing on a stage with this was hard
to understand i i had to watch it a few
times i really get it i watched it
several times and i still don't know
what he's talking about but the the best
part is about this entire thing is he's
standing in front of a big huge wall
that has truth
like plastered all over it yeah well
that's the best part about it they love
to brand [ __ ] with truth you got truth
social you got the truth summit it would
like me be trying to brand myself as
some kind of non-cursing christian like
that is not what i am why would i why
would i try to brand myself that way i'm
not i'm just not that but they try to
brand themselves as the truth when he
says
just i mean this is just
word sal i mean word salad should even
be offended at this like seriously word
salad should be like hey wait a second
that is not word salad that's not proper
word cell that is
something way beyond but i also want to
i also want to point out like this is
the best person like the republican
party could have could have nominated
anyone or could have pushed anyone in
terms of of backing them for well they
had a former senator they had a former
senator in their state that could be the
so that's what i'm that's that's what is
most confusing like this is the best
representative like if you're going to
put on policy and people like who know
the system and know how and know how
government works why wouldn't you put
that person behind why are you putting
someone who is a football player former
football player that clearly is
working through some stuff has has a
history of domestic violence like why is
this domestic violence violence in
general this guy has pulled weapons on
people right and he's put weapons to his
head and pulled the tr he's just he's
not he's not right he's not right and
this uh it
shows you why he's not right let's
listen we ought to defend our military
[Applause]
[Music]
is the music in the background added to
this or is it playing while he's going
i'm not really sure on this clip don't
know
but um but there's music and it's like
boo boo boo boo so i'm not sure if he's
like using it as a hype music while he's
talking about wokeness in the military
which again it's more with this wokeness
in the military stuff but then you know
and i guess you could determine where
he's going but then he takes really um
he
jumps right off the [ __ ] word salad
cliff here listen
and uh
talking about being a superpower
and the way we can become a superpower
again
what what
is he is he talking about superhero
movies here he's like we're gonna be
super power and identifying russia and
then in china's is they're gonna clean
their air and then well they're gonna
identify clean air what the [ __ ] is he
makes this he makes this argument about
how like those in power or control
instigate fighting amongst
uh
instigate fighting within those who are
beneath them to kind of keep them
distracted i think that's what he was
talking about when i originally listened
to this
i don't know it was so crazy i was like
this is [ __ ] nuts i gotta forget
well let's let's finish up here
see and then and then when he invokes
the whole slaves in order thing and it
just man it just
oh
if you need more of a reason to [ __ ]
go vote i don't know
what i can do to help you out but this
is the people that they want to put in
charge of your economy day one herschel
walker on [ __ ] senate committees
making choices
about your future
this is what the republican party i
don't think it's actually that what
people of georgia want
i actually don't know i'm also sure
that's not what the people of
pennsylvania want when it comes to
doctor oz the whack [ __ ] you've never
seen the [ __ ] sign thing oh the no
you've seen the sign thing oh my god i'm
surprised that no one has done that like
i didn't even
i did not think of that but it's
brilliant i don't even know but i've
been seeing them all weekend where i'm
like oh my god this marketing campaign
of people just flipping signs is
hilarious they turn that sign upside
down the uh or it's turn it sideways
right and the sign says no and then
someone had no on because you turn it
the other way now it's on exactly yeah
no on odds that's
when it i will say this when it comes to
making a logo you definitely made
something that is uh
is universally
uh you know
uh a weapon
against you right it couldn't say like
doctor mehmed oz and it's like oh maybe
you might be have a hard time kind of
flip it but they're like you know dr oz
and then it becomes no on
you know whatever you want it to be
well being being so i don't know being
as that they're desperate because here's
another story over the weekend did you
did you watch uh january 6th select
committee released a it's about an eight
minute video we're not going to watch it
here i've got it retweeted and really
you can go to the january 6 select
committee twitter um you can watch this
eight minute video did you watch that
new piece of uh video that they released
because we've seen parts of it where it
talks about the it talks about the the
real electors the fake collectors it
kind of compares them
but it talks about ron johnson in this
new piece
well also didn't ron johnson come out
he's like look i was only involved for
like a few seconds right well he told he
uh yeah yeah he said they well he said
uh i was only
i was only treasonous for a couple
seconds so it doesn't count something
like that yeah i was like good guys guys
look i only held up the gun and walked
into the bank for a second and then i
said you know what
this is probably a question i should do
this today we're gonna probably i'm
gonna have someone else do this in my
own name because listen listen to this
nun listen to this russian stooge on fox
news this week and try to justify how he
was trying to overthrow our government
the russia collusion hoax real quick
your election right now in wisconsin you
say they are interfering in your
election because of these smears on you
let's take a look at where you stand in
wisconsin tell me about your opponent
and why you believe you right now are
being smeared and this is uh the
so this is um a fox news poll by the way
yeah and that fox news is putting up
here wow ron johnson and it is
it has mandela barnes winning
outside the margin of eric is the margin
of error in this case of this poll which
again you got to be careful with these
polls because i think they're dead wrong
um yeah and i don't mean that they're
opposite dead wrong i just mean they're
way off i think they're way off uh we've
seen that in new york's 19th we've seen
that in kansas so i actually think
mandela barnes probably has more than
more than a four point lead on ron
johnson probably more like a ten point
lead with the three percent margin of
error but even if you consider this poll
to be something that you would cite here
as evidence of how the race is going for
ron johnson mandela barnes who is almost
unknown in wisconsin at this point and
still unknown getting to be known they
need to be he needs to be more known
within the next you know two months
but he's even beating ron johnson
outside the margin of error in the fox
news poll right of all things
um now this is really funny how they
frame this up right when she's asking
ron johnson the russian asset asked
questions like oh the democrats accused
for years that there was collusion and
corruption and 2000 there was now we
know that now we know bill bart buried
that in the mueller report right
now that we know that that's the truth
and we've been saying it for [ __ ]
years that billboard did that
but
now now
now we're supposed to believe that
russia is rigging it against ron johnson
in wisconsin is what we're supposed to
believe the guy who went to russia and
had had barbecue with putin on the
fourth of july on our independence day
we're supposed to believe now putin is
gonna is gonna go against his stooge
that is ron johnson inside the u.s
senate get the [ __ ] out of here listen
the uh results uh 50 for barnes 46 for
johnson in the wisconsin senate race
well again because of their suppression
they absolutely interfered in the 2020
election far greater than anything
russia or china could ever do and yes by
by leaking that briefing uh basically
saying i'm a tool of russia which i am
not
oh i get what they're saying here
they're not saying russia's interfering
what they're saying is
um american political parties are are
participating in elections they're mad
well they're mad that we're politicizing
[ __ ] it's it's anything that goes
against them right if there is any
narrative you saw last night with uh
with lindsey graham right you you see it
with josh hawley donald trump ted cruz
like any of these people any of these
people from the republican party
who find something that goes against
their narrative right against what they
believe they don't get their way
they
kick and scream and whine that it was
unfair it was a cheat they were rigged
uh
and on top of that you'll have a group
who has already projected their own
thug
threatening behavior to other people
they do that you saw that last night
with lindsey graham you saw it before
january 6 you see it after january 6
these people
threaten the way of life of other people
when they don't get their way
they they [ __ ] and scream and cry and
whine and they say it's not fair
they took it from me
they're politicizing that i'm a traitor
right and they they
people like ron johnson don't like the
fact that when democracy is working and
people are given an equal opportunity to
vote for whoever they want and they have
a fox news poll that [ __ ] says you're
losing
you say it's suppression it's
suppression it's the deep state and this
is collusion and they're cheating and
blah blah blah it's like no
that's just people have
the right to express which candidate
they want to vote for and you happen to
be not the majority in this situation
right they don't like that you're a
russian stooge you bunch of goddamn
[ __ ] right
you're just a bunch of goddamn [ __ ]
which is the other thing too is like i
i find it funny that a lot of these
republican
legislators are like oh no i gotta stay
in politics i guarantee if they left
politics they could do way more [ __ ]
damage with the influence of lobbying or
other private think tanks or right
leaning
companies like the influence that they
would have on other representatives you
know the fear is that democrats take
over a pro republican seat but
when it comes to power and influence i'm
i'm kind of surprised that these people
like ron johnson are like oh no this is
oh this is unfair and i'm going to get
cheated blah blah blah it's like dude
just accept the loss and just [ __ ]
take the take the money that's at the
end of the [ __ ] road right now
because you're going to do cash go cash
your russian paycheck right because
here's the thing as soon as they lose
they will immediately go to the private
sector and they'll make a [ __ ] ton of
money doing something crazy against our
own democracy like that's what will
happen well what whatever that where
wherever that that threat may be they'll
lean into that threat that they really
this is again this points out my whole
point and what this show is all about is
they are terrified they are [ __ ]
terrified of democracy they are
terrified of it so much so that she
shows him a poll on the station that he
feels comfortable going on because he's
feels safe that their pole even shows
that they don't [ __ ] like you because
you're a russian stooge and that's what
he's mad about he's mad that we me and
us are [ __ ] politicizing that he's a
russian stooge he's like wait a second
that's what we're supposed to do to you
you aren't supposed to politicize stuff
you're supposed to talk about line items
and bills and argue amongst yourselves
why we take over the democracy and undo
it and and make sure that you don't have
rights that's what's supposed to happen
and i'm really frustrated that you're
using your power of your ballot and
you're using democracy against me that
terrifies me let's listen completely
false accusation the wisconsin press
picks that up and their people in
wisconsin think i'm a tool of vladimir
putin nothing could be further from the
truth but they have smeared me publicly
and they just might impact the 2022
election here in wisconsin as well
because let's face it marie maria they
do not want me re-elected because i
would be chairman of the permission
subcommittee investigations they know i
will investigate their corruption no no
wisconsin doesn't want you elected dumb
[ __ ] yeah because they know you're a
russian stooge just what you said you
they always run face first into it like
just they barrel right into it
and they can't see
the forest for the trees i mean they do
it's impressive really how much they're
able to run through a wall
and keep running
right
say the point
and and not catch on at all right like
they they are olympic athletes
at this they are impressive it really is
it's impressive and scary that they're
able to just [ __ ] run right through
the point and even when someone's like
hey hey you you just made the point
against yourself
you know you're proving this they can
[ __ ] run right through it again and
make the point again
and they keep you know it's like it's
like [ __ ] hulk like smashing through
walls just like keep going through
they don't stop and they don't realize
it um and i don't know i mean i think
the american people are catching on to
it the american people and because of
people like this who are leaders of
their party marjorie taylor greene is
the leader of their party at this point
and she is out there saying some crazy
[ __ ] over the weekend this is just one
this is just one moment of it and again
this is our or is this or this is from
the moment of truth are they still doing
this
or is this old clip am i pulling an old
clip here because again they use the
truth the word truth right and they
can't stop don't use
it i thought it was just i mean unless
this one let me know
let me play it while you're looking it
up let's listen to what bonehead says
because she was born in the week last
week she's obviously um wanting to be in
contention this week but let's listen to
what the bone end says here about
merrick garland and holding accountable
she sounds scared as [ __ ] to me let's
listen merritt garland he didn't just
step across the line he went like he
like ran through the line and ran a
whole football
field length past it and he you know you
mean the line of of prosecution like he
hasn't crossed the line of prosecution
yet like where the american people are
actually waiting for him to barrel
through that barrier is to start
indicting you dumb [ __ ] this
also looks like it was this is from the
previous week oh this is during this i
don't i don't know i mean like all the
other crazy [ __ ] she said this is just
now coming today yeah yeah yeah it looks
like uh i mean this is from
that weekend was the 27 august 22nd so
that
was
when all this [ __ ] went down we're still
seeing great content that we can use to
politicize these people again what ron
johnson's accusing us of is exactly what
we're doing we are politicizing this we
are going to politicize the [ __ ] out of
you people being fascist and wanting to
take our democracy away from god damn
right we are but let's listen to how she
is scared af we fire people in the
private sector for for doing bad things
same thing needs to happen in the
government he needs to be fired he is a
radical communist and he's abusing
okay what the best part about this whole
thing is that these people actually
believe that merrick garland is a
radical communist are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
me do they know do they know that
merrick garland is actually a member of
the federalist society do they have any
clue no they don't well they don't they
don't well it's just danny garland
merrick garland is supposed to be some
kind of radical communist right what are
you talking about this is so [ __ ]
hilarious because
people on the left
rather be legitimate or absolute just
trying to spread fear to their
supporters yeah have been calling for
merrick garland because he's not radical
enough
he's not communist enough or whatever
you want to say and here she's calling
him a radical communist make your
[ __ ] minds up right either merrick
garland is a tool for the left our
merrick garland is a tool for the right
will you people crazy boneheads out
there decide
whether merrick garland is a tool for
someone or he's just doing his [ __ ]
job like yes
he's done his entire career right i
would say that this is not one of those
things where it's like he's a tool for
the right or tool for love he's just a
tool for justice right he's doing his
job he's like hey job he's always this
guy
over here trump you know arrested or
sorry uh uh committed a crime and we
should do something to we should need to
investigate right whether that leads to
conviction arrest whatever
someone did a crime we look into it
that's our job i don't pick sides or
play favorites i play favorite two or i
i do my job that is justice and
democracy and making sure that we don't
[ __ ] uh have a land full of of
traitors and sedition and and people
violating the espionage act and people
obstructing justice right and that's
only just from this situation that's not
even including what's happening in
georgia or new york or dc like you have
all these other things where you know
when this first came out and they're
like
the search warrant happened and
the fbi went through uh mar-a-lago and
everyone was like
first question uh for which crime right
like nobody knew originally what the
crime was for which is always a really
reassuring thing to have for a former
president to be like
i assumed he was gonna this was gonna
happen just didn't know for which one
like gotta check the bingo card to see
which one i got
and and stuff like this where they're
like oh he's a tool for the left or like
he's not doing a job or like he's he's
playing favorites it's [ __ ] this is
a party that is afraid
and they're freaking the [ __ ] out
because they might be associated or
identified in some investigation you
know whether they saw the documents or
they heard the documents were there or
whatever it might be
right these you know for for a thing
that's called the truth summit it is not
very truthful right you you've also got
if you look at the table they got
[ __ ] tinctures and essential oils and
creams and something else right out
front
same stuff as alex jones where they're
like look you guys are all idiots that
are watching this and i can sell this
[ __ ] and shove it down your throat and
you will pay
[ __ ] all the time every time just
like you do with trump
like it is insane i bet it says oil on
these bots oh i guarantee i guarantee
right those those little droppers the
little droppers probably like a tincture
or like an essential oil if i had to
guess right this other thing over here
looks like soap these things at the
bottom look like maybe chapsticks right
that you put on like those they're like
hey you got truth summit branded [ __ ]
chapstick right so the only thing that
comes out of your mouth is truth right
like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
these people are just scammers they're
grifting you and these people do not
realize it but they're also the same
people that are willing to
regurgitate the same narrative that
trump declassified and this was unjust
and it was unfair and he's not a
criminal well it's speaking of the same
people saying this is on some [ __ ]
trader news network at some
some traitor expo listen to what she
says about humanitarian aid this is this
is weird what else does it do it funds
and i'm going to use the word it's
confusing to people humanitarian aid
how is that confusing it's wonderful and
i love humanitarian aid but oh she does
she does she loves it butt game but
but there's always a butt with these
people there is always a butt with i'm
not racist but i'm not a fascist but
like there's always a butt with these
people let's listen to why she doesn't
believe humanitarian aid is a good thing
because of a butt
it is our american tax dollars are
so-called funding humanitarian aid in
places like ukraine that that is
basically
like that that that money is just go in
people's pockets it is it's like washing
marger taylor green just blew the lid
off this
one gosh the breaking news this is
incredible marjorie tater green lies
again on a television trader tv news
network and we think it's right breaking
news these people really are stupid
really
just the fact that
you have this this woman who's willing
to even comment on humanitarian aid
while
also being the recipient of you know a
few hundred thousand but paid off uh you
know got 138 000 or so
for given
of ppp loan money right we're talking
about humanitarian aid
let's talk about what the real intended
goal of the ppp like the the loan money
was it was to help small businesses to
help people survive during a pandemic
who were given 600 1200 1800 max
in an 18 month to two year two year
period right
someone that says oh you know
humanitarian aid sounds good yeah it
does sound good when you actually
[ __ ] use it and don't abuse it
that is what she does she found she knew
what was going to happen
she abused the application got money and
got it forgiven for whatever excuse that
was the paycheck that she gave right
or the payroll that she gave
and just one of those things where it's
like
this party is full of projection and and
they want to say that
it's not fair
it's unjust
you know uh this is totally rigged
speaking of speaking of projection
here's ron johnson's cousin and marjorie
taylor green and donald trump's
threesome buddy you saw them on the
balcony at the uh
at the uh oh yeah they were they were
chumming it up man do you do you think
there's something to that you know these
people are obsessed with sex and
and
i don't know if if they're part of the
orgies that i am no one catherine was
talking about but i'm just asking
questions here i'm just asking questions
i'm just asking questions that's a
question that's all i'm doing uh let's
let's let's watch tucker here um
open his mouth and let putin uh bury his
little mushroom
right deep down inside his throat listen
it was russian propaganda russian
disinformation neither those terms has
an agreed upon meaning they don't
actually mean anything actually actually
words do have meaning like these are
things like i can't even believe that
someone watching this is like does he
really believe that i'm that [ __ ]
dumb that words don't have meanings
i mean i mean well i mean that's you
know this [ __ ] type of trash is just
ridiculous he has he has you know
definitely fought that legally to say
like the things i say no right person in
their own mind you know or right right
state of mind would believe that what i
say
is real you have to be
[ __ ] gullible or dumb to think that
what i say and what i tell you every
night is news that's what he argued he
said i'm not news i'm entertainment
right
well but but gay propaganda and russian
propaganda those don't have meaning
let's let's hear
his really delusional logic behind it
how he deep throats
putin here it's russian propaganda is it
true
that should be the only question that
any news or information company
including facebook
is true
truth is the defense
no it's russian propaganda again a term
without a meaning
again with the truth thing again with
the [ __ ]
thing they love they love to spit truth
you know oh my god is that why he
couldn't get a trademark on it because
they're all going after that [ __ ]
thing i don't know it's [ __ ] weird
man i don't know it's like they're like
no if we just car lies truth enough
people will they'll believe it right
it is
it is dumb
and it is also completely
uh expected
for a group to you know i make i make a
joke about like putting a true summit
[ __ ] chapstick on your mouth and now
truth is what comes out right despite
the fact it's all [ __ ] right right
just because you put something on that
says true doesn't make what you say
truth you know
but they're obsessed they project they
love to say truth they say we are the
truth we tell you the truth right i mean
it sounds pretty similar to some
propagandist uh gaslighting tactics that
a certain group in germany had wait wait
are you talking about a certain point in
history
is that what you're talking about like
you're saying birdies in 1940s does that
ring a bell i'm saying i'm just saying
yeah that's what i'm saying well here's
uh speaking of nazis
there's a lesbian dance theory uh clip
you gotta see this i can't go without
showing this clip i mean i know it's
it's hard but it's only 19 seconds of uh
cringe let's let's listen uh how the
heck can joe biden call america first
conservatives a threat to democracy with
a straight face and why i mean he did it
because dude she rehearsed this so
[ __ ] much in front of the mirror
she did not come up with this right out
of the gate she knew which part which
part this part or the end that the thing
the thing that she thinks is a slam dunk
i think well
the definitely the latter of the two but
i think that this whole this whole bit
right here like this is like a little
quip that she was like i'm gonna say
this on the show
you know it's gonna really get them like
we're really gonna make sure that all
these these semi-fascists which i think
joe biden is derelict in his duty when
he's calling these people semi-fascists
that's my faster [ __ ] nazis listen to
this garbage dry diaper he's the one who
has allowed millions to invade our
southern border he's the one who is
robbing hard-working americans to pay
for karen's daughter's degree in lesbian
dance theory
so what she's claiming here is that all
this is this is really stupid this is
the over calculation that they always do
the miscalculation that they made with
roe the miscalculation that they made
with that they make with weapons of war
and actual reasonable gun gun reform
this is the miscalculation that they
always make
what she's saying here is that anyone
who is going to receive 10 000
which is a drop in the bucket compared
to what their actual college bill was
that's probably won't even pay for the
[ __ ] interest of the life of the loan
but right just because someone pays gets
10 000
relieved not given to them relieved on
their loan
she thinks that only people who got a
degree and
lesbian dancer which by the way
honestly if i was going to go back to
school
i don't know that i wouldn't i mean that
sounds like a pretty good [ __ ] major
to me it sounds like a pretty fun
it sounds
right like there are many ways when
like if
the way that republicans try to make
insults right it always comes back to
say
uh
we [ __ ] got you guys we [ __ ] owned
you whether it's the [ __ ] liberal [ __ ]
lubricant on your ar15 [ __ ]
or it's lesbian dancer or it's dark
brandon or like let's go brandon like or
i did that all of these things are never
done with the foresight in mind to be
like this is gonna like backfire on this
this right back because none of the
tactics are future proof they never they
don't future proof them to be like in
the next three months
we've got you or whatever time frame but
then beyond that six nine months a year
like is this gonna come back and bite us
in the ass no one ever thinks about that
[ __ ]
no one ever puts that in consideration
and so when it does come back it [ __ ]
blows up in their face which is lesbian
dance theory one that sounds ridiculous
coming from person who has
barely got her ged potentially paid
someone to take the gigi i don't know
allegedly those are rumors definitely
took her a few tries
but to comment on things that she
doesn't know about right because she's
i'm going to get a funny report here
it's going to be so good i'm going to
i'm gonna get him i'm gonna get the
liberals so good it's like
when do you say it probably
when you say it blows back in their
faces is that part of the ar-15
phrasing
phrasing
i'm not i'm not saying that's what
happens
however they do it well speaking of a
lesbian dance theory you posted this
lesbian dance theory will now be taught
by patriot front because i think you're
right this is um
this may be some evidence of the classes
that we as american people are paying
for
this may be a uh outside lesbian dance
theory class let's let's watch
i mean they're kind of
it's kind of in sync there's no music
a little
bit
this is what oh my god they so this is
their this is them preparing to be like
oh if we were out and about and
something happened and we need to defend
this is the civil war that they're gonna
do is this a civil right right right
so they would you know they're like all
right we gotta then
go from the front circle around the back
don't don't expose our backs which like
i get that but the way in which you
side shuffle and then shuffle back into
the back
you know
coming after one who's coming after you
okay no one is [ __ ] coming after you
guys you guys get into penske and you
haul [ __ ] trucks you unload you then
go somewhere people call you out because
nobody [ __ ] likes you your bunch of
incels then you go back into the truck
you get busted by the fbi because
someone in there was you know a ci
uh and then you have these training
videos like they think that these videos
help them in making them seem so tough
so macho but it doesn't it like it is
[ __ ] laughable people within the
military community
online are [ __ ] dragging these guys
right now because they're like
that is definitely not something we've
ever trained for even people in
hollywood i had people commenting from
that are other actors
like big time actors that were
commenting on the video they're like yep
never had this type of training when i
when i train for military movie roles
right when they when they have to
actually when when a consultant trains
what
they're supposed to look like they're
like this doesn't look like anything
like that you know what you know what
like seal tim six this is exactly what
we do when we went in to [ __ ] get uh
osama bin laden and it's like sure thing
you sure about that you know this should
be put to line dancing music i'm sure
somebody in my somebody if you go into
the comments yeah somebody did i don't
know if it's gonna get flagged though so
i
i'm unsure
i'm unsure somebody did put music to it
okay well here is somebody else did
some of them it looks like um maybe one
of them here let's let's see it might
get flagged so if you can't hear the
music because it goes away that's why
[Music]
i've been here
[Music]
and then they do a jig you know
[Music]
if it's perfect it fits perfect this is
exactly what i was thinking
it's great i mean it is it is amazing uh
but yeah all these guys they think that
they are the
manly of man they are going to they are
they are the superior race the superior
gender that they're going to save this
country from
anyone who isn't white because the
racist and the fascists and they're just
you know
they're going to be taken down but
if it got silenced here on youtube the
music was cot nine joe
so just imagine
that the music was scott and i joe
as the video was playing
it's absolutely it's it's just i don't
know about you but
i'm sure this dance or
military preparation style that the
patriot front men are doing are making
all the women
super into them oh i'm very attracted
they're like oh
oh boy
but wait a second they don't yeah but
they're against whops so they you don't
want to go that far they're against
swaps um we have a few trending topics
here
before we go that i want to mention
it looks like marsha blackburn uh
tweeted something oh about tennessee
bird nest hair yeah
they don't want socialism which is
absolutely untrue um real america is
turning inside i would imagine jim
jordan has figured out that the gas
prices are dropping in this little tire
it's 70
like seven days straight something like
that is it is well yeah it's like mid
seven almost almost it's near near
oh my god i i seriously i did not go
into this thread i
i promise and i knew it was that
[ __ ] i knew it was that
[ __ ]
and [ __ ] trader ass piece of [ __ ] no
i'm serious i haven't been in this
thread yet i don't even think i put it
on the damn tweet as that's a trend that
we would get to it just popped up as a
real america and i guessed it right here
live that it was jim jordan tweeting and
what do you what do you know well i mean
if people doubt you they can always go
through the actual uh
feed and see what you were looking at so
well i'm telling you
help me help me you can also get your
doubt me merge speaking to that uh on
store.nettonemichaels.com hot flying off
the shelves that doubt me merch because
doubt me i'm telling you i know these
things these things are not hard to know
really honestly they're these it it
really is they make it easy for me to to
me for me to say doubt me so get your
doubt me stickers mugs shirts and
hoodies and wear them proudly and tell
all these [ __ ] idiots exactly uh who
they are but jim jordan here tweets i
have not even uh pre-read this here not
to know but i know it's [ __ ] dumb as
[ __ ] because he's tweeting it in real
america as opposed to fake america i
guess
you work hard pay your bills
and provide for your family
isn't that how it should be what the oh
oh i i know what he's saying here he's
saying he's saying people who do work
hard who pay their bills and provide for
their families and went to college and
are going to get actual relief from
their student loan debt he's he's he's
dehumanizing them here yep he's
demeaning him he's punching down
he's punching down on his own
constituents that are going to receive
student loan debt relief i mean
especially especially because those
constituents when he says real america
which again yeah it's like what does it
mean that we're living in fake america
or like we are in a different reality in
our mindset maybe that's what he's
trying to say but when he says real
america people are doing this this this
right like
that's great you work hard yeah you
should be able to pay your bills and
provide your family however
however tony
in our current state of real america or
fake america whatever he [ __ ] thinks
it is
people who do work
hard
multiple jobs
still cannot pay their bills
still cannot provide for their family
because of certain deaths they may have
acquired from higher education right
they went to school and they weren't
able to get that job because they didn't
have the right amount of experience and
now they are only stuck within a certain
pay range minimum wage is something that
certainly isn't helping by keeping that
suppressed down so when somebody says
like jim jordan the [ __ ] obtuse out
of touch
uh you know turns a blind eye to sexual
assault on his wrestling team
that type of person has no idea what the
[ __ ] they're talking about
so when they come forward and say in
real america people work hard and they
pay their bills and fight for the family
i want to say that the people of ohio
are probably struggling like everyone
else in
in this country and those people are are
working hard and are trying to provide
for their family and are trying to pay
for their bills but they can't because
people like jim jordan don't want to
help them do you know what i think the
game is here
you want to know what i think the game
is here i think the game is here is that
people like jim jordan and let me pull
this back up because i think this is
important for people understand what's
going on here
um
jim people like jim jordan uh he knows
that these dumb [ __ ] are listening to
some degree listening to what they're
saying
and they act on what they say because
the ten thousand dollars
is not given to you
despite what ted cruz may say like
you're gonna get twenty thousand dollars
that's not how that works no one's
writing you a check and the other thing
too that i think is
is is uh being
a little misreported here and i wanna
report it here
on the tony michaels podcast because
we're not journalists but this is a fact
you have to apply for this thing gabe
yep here's what that means is that if
you are listening to someone like jim
jordan
and you are enough of a bonehead to to
think that because you're going to
accept ten thousand dollars in student
debt relief you're not hard-working
you're not someone who likes to pay
their bills and you do not provide for
your family
that you are not going to apply for this
that means what they're doing is they're
doing the same thing with the gas prices
the same thing with the with the coveted
checks and all this [ __ ]
is what they're doing is they're setting
it up to where they can have people on
interview like no i'm a hard worker i
didn't get any debt relief when really
the truth is they didn't actually apply
for it they didn't apply for it because
here's what's going to happen the people
who are against student debt relief are
not going to go look up how to get it
they're not going to care about how to
get it well some of them will they'll
actually get it and say they didn't get
it but but then they're going to go
interview people and say look joe biden
didn't give it to trump supporters he
didn't give them student debt they
didn't actually receive it the
government didn't write them a check or
some stupid [ __ ]
they're setting up a false [ __ ]
narrative a false [ __ ] thing where
he is convincing people out there not to
actually apply for what they are
entitled to now
is their student debt relief the ten
thousand dollars twenty whatever
it's like the same thing as like don't
vote
right don't vote because it's rigged i
mean five books don't read books don't
if you don't if you don't wanna vote
then you tell your constituents not to
vote and if they don't vote that's on
them but like the democratic party is
not going to suppress restrict or
oppress anyone from the ability to vote
we're going to practice democracy and
say you should go vote we want to have
more ballot boxes we can drop them off
then you have these people who are like
no no no
out of a population of millions there's
only one like in [ __ ] texas right
like it's it is their it's their their
game their strategy that they play
and i wouldn't well the only thing is
i
would be very curious to know
how many people related to the people uh
that are republicans in
senators representatives what have you
that end up applying for this program
not the people obviously that are in
because they
they don't make or they are
outside of the range of the 125 000
but i would be curious to know how many
family members related
or friends related to those sitting
legislators
are going to apply and be accepted for
that necessary aid and assistance to
forgive their student loans
well i think there's going to be a lot
of people because of jim jordan's little
statement here who don't go get their
ten thousand dollars of relief and
student done it and not because they're
not hard-working not because they don't
pay the bills or provide for the family
they're just absolute uh
deluded twits that believe anything that
these [ __ ] boneheads say and it's of
their own detriment and really honestly
it's sad to see that americans are
putting themselves in in real america
which is the the actual fake part of
america that's the projection here is
the fake part of america the people who
are deluded are listening to their uncle
earl and their aunt edna on facebook
about the delusional [ __ ] that's going
on
they're the ones that are gonna miss out
on what america is really about here and
and you know
i guess it's your choice to be stupid in
this country you do have the choice but
it is important for you to use your
choice for you to use your voice and to
go out and participate and engage in
your ballot democracy we are two hours
already i know how fast was that two
hours it's monday it's monday tomorrow's
tuesday and we are here every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch don't forget
to subscribe to the youtube channel you
don't want to miss a thing we also
simulcast from the midas touch facebook
page go follow us on twitter at
tonymichaelspod and also download every
single episode gabe every single one of
them yep on every single one spotify
apple leave us a great review while
you're there it would help us out even
if you listen uh live you can go
re-listen to our beautiful voices on all
your favorite directories
thank you very much for joining us we
will see you tomorrow same time same
place
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking